it's to india now where prime minister
narendra modi has led a ceremony to
inaugurate the building of a hindu
temple
that has been at the center of a bitter
century-old dispute
between hindus and muslims the temple
will be erected on the site of a
demolished mosque
the ayodhya temple site was being
heavily guarded
ahead of that inauguration chronovirus
restrictions mean that the ceremony is
low-key
and not open to regular worshipers
the mosque once on that site was torn
down by hindu nationalist
mobs in 1992 that's file footage there
the
there are fears that putting a hindu
temple
in its place will reignite tensions
between the two communities
for more on this let's go now to dw's
namisha jaiswal
joining us from delhi good day to you
namisha why
is this site this location for the
construction of a hindu temple
so very divisive inside india
well brian hindus believe that the site
marks the place
where lord rama a revered hindu god was
born
and claim it as such so the construction
the beginning of this construction
is seen as a way for the community to
reclaim a space
that they felt was originally theirs of
course this was contentious
because there was a mosque built there
which was demolished
three decades ago now the campaign for
the building
of this temple has been three decades
long and has also accompanied
and has been closely tied to the rise of
prime minister narendra modi's bjp
the starting of this construction is
seen as as the delivery of a key pole
promise
by the bjp the date of this construction
initiation is also significant and also
ties to another key pole promise
exactly one year ago today the narendra
modi government
abrogated the special status of kashmir
and removed its semi-autonomous status
now while the government says this was
to promote economic development as well
as better integration
of the state of jammu and kashmir but
there has been criticism and opposition
to the move as well we can hear more
about this criticism in the report here
[Music]
outrage in the indian parliament on
august 5th
last year the indian government stunned
opposition lawmakers by announcing it
was revoking kashmir's semi-autonomy
the basis of the region's complex
relationship with india for decades
the special status of jammu and kashmir
is going to be automatically null and
void
[Music]
the hindu nationalist government said
the move was necessary to spur
economic development and to better
integrate the region with the rest of
the country
the opposition was shocked
today the ruling party bjp has buried
the constitution
and the democracy
[Applause]
as a result seven million people in the
kashmir valley were put under lockdown
for months the government severely
restricted freedom of movement
and banned gatherings it cut land lines
and mobile phones
and even shut down the internet
thousands of people were arrested
including three former chief ministers
reportedly hundreds of people still
remain
under house arrest or behind bars mostly
without charge
there are also reports of torture indian
authorities
deny the allegations neighboring
pakistan
still condemns india's actions since the
5th
of august the illegal measures taken by
india
there is a new fervor there's a new wave
a new wave of resentment against the
atrocities being committed
across the llc be rest assured
the people of pakistan stand with you
and he adds kashmir will be part of
pakistan
inshallah pakistan
at the anniversary of the autonomy
revocation the kashmir conflict seems as
far from resolution
as ever and little seems to have changed
in the region itself
fearing violent protests the government
has again
imposed a new curfew
namisha one year after kashmir had its
autonomy revoked by delhi can you tell
us more
about what's changed for the people
there for kashmiris
well brian when we look at the conflict
on region and the tensions that have
abided there for the last few decades
not much has changed the government
claimed that this was for economic
development and better integration
as well as better security and there
have been more operations carried out
against error networks however this has
also been criticized
as increasing insecurity amongst the
people
who are traumatized by the increase in
violence and have also seen
the move to abrogate krishna's special
status as unilateral
there was also a lockdown that continued
for a while after the abrogation of this
special status
and for six months there was no internet
soon after
2g internet was restored the corona
virus lockdown hit which has further
hit the economy of the region there's
losses estimated of a tune
of 5 billion dollars and tourism is also
severely hit
thanks so much for for bringing this up
um on a very important day for filling
us in
namisha jaiswal our correspondent in
delhi thank you
you